François miteran a connu Bernard Henry
Levi BHL pour les intimes l'ancien
président français a connu BHL assez
jeune voici ce qu'il dit de lui dans son
livre l'abeille et l'architecte j'ai
connu Bernard Henri levvi alors qu'il
venait d'entrer à normal supérieur je me
flatte d'avoir pressenti en ce jeune
homme grave le grand écrivain qu'il sera
un danger le getet la
[Musique]
mode BL est-il devenu un grand écrivain
pour l'instant il n'est pas considéré
comme tel en revanche il est bien à la
mode les sondages réalisés dans les
années 2010 montrent qu'il est
l'intellectuel le plus connu des
Français mais il est aussi controversé
son influence médiatico-politique et sa
proximité avec les puissants en font un
symbole de la dimension oligarchique des
élite française et effectivement ce qui
est étonnant dans le destin de BHL c'est
la concentration des pouvoirs il aurait
pu se contenter d'être riche il aurait
pu se contenter d'être influent il
aurait pu se contenter d'écrire des
bestsellers mais il fera tout cela à la
fois comment est-ce que c'est possible
je vais vous répondre à travers 10
anecdotes vraiment étonnantes sur la vie
de Bel peut-être que vous ne l'aimez pas
mais écoutez-moi jusqu'au bout vous ne
le regretterez
pas après la campagne présidentielle de
2007 sort un nouveau livre de BL ce
grand cadavre à la renverse qui parle du
déclin de la gauche française dont
béachel dit qu'elle est sa famille
politique la métaphore du Grand cadavre
à la renverse et de Sartre un des
modèles de béhl dans ce livre BHL accuse
Jean-Pierre Chevenement qui est l'homme
politique emblématique du souverainisme
de gauche en France c'est-à-dire une
vision politique qui ambitionne de
limiter les écarts de richesse grâce à
l'indépendance du pays BHL accuse
Jean-Pierre cheveninement d'avoir
saboter la campagne de la candidate
socialiste à l'élection de 2007 c'est
Golen Royal réponse de Chevénement la
place que font les médias au sieur
Bernard Henry levvi milliardaire déguisé
en philosophe est révélatrice du profond
abaissement intellectuel moral et même
spirituel de ce moment de notre histoire
milliardaire déguisé en philosophe cette
critique colle à la peau de BHL en 2011
il défend DSK qui est son ami lors de
l'affaire du Sofitel cela provoque des
réactions ulcérées de la presse
américaine dans le concert de critique
le rédacteur en chef du magazine reason
qualifie BHL de milliardair narcissiqu à
la chemise déboutonnée même aux
États-Unis on lui reproche sa fortune
mais milliardaires vraiment en franc
peut-être et encore selon les
estimations les plus hautes elle varie
entre plusieurs dizaines et une centaine
de millions d'euros BHL hérite de cette
fortune en 1997 lorsque l'entreprise
d'importation de bois de son père
disparu de an plusut tôt est revendu en
quasi intégralité à l'homme d'affair
François Pinot qui est lui pour le coup
un vrai milliardaire si les critiques de
BL le qualifient de milliardaire ce
n'est donc pas parce qu'il a ce niveau
de richesse mais plutôt parce que son
train de vie semble incompatible avec un
rapport philosophique à l'existence
c'est vrai que dans l'imaginaire
occidental le philosophe trouve son
épanouissement dans la pensée pas dans
le luxe le philosophe se contente de peu
comme Épicure il met sa force morale à
l'épreuve comme les stoïciens voire il
vit comme un asset en rejetant les biens
matériels comme dieugène le cynique B
elle lui a un train de vie de
millionnaire à Paris il évolue
essentiellement dans le chic quartier de
Saint-Germain des pré qui est le cœur de
la vie intellectuelle parisienne il a
des domestiques et un chauffeur il
fréquente également les hôtels les plus
luxueux du monde entier il les considère
comme son bureau d'écrivain par ailleurs
si BHL n'est pas lui-même milliardaire
il fréquente des milliardaires il est
par exemple l'ami de François Pinot qui
a racheté l'entreprise de son père et de
Jean-Luc lag gardèer qui était à la fin
du 20e siècle un Mania des médias si BHL
n'a pas une fortune compar leur il est
lui aussi un patron d'entreprise des
sociétés de gestion de patrimoine
d'investissement de production de
musique ou de cinéma et puis il a
également une expérience du monde de
l'entreprise du vivant de son père il
était en charge de la communication
interne de l'entreprise familiale avant
d'en devenir le
vice-président nous sommes en mai 68 BHL
est en prépa littéraire à Louis Legrand
comme beaucoup d'étudiants il adhère aux
idées révolutionnaire qui déferle sur la
société française mais voilà il ne peut
pas participer aux manifestations il
préfère réviser pour le concours de
l'École normale supérieure alors que le
concours approche certains de ses
camarades le poussent à boycotter les
examens d'entrée par solidarité avec les
manifestants BHL refuse il paraît qu'il
était même un de ceux qui ont fait
pression sur les autorités de l'école
afin que le concours soit maintenu
malgré les événements le concours a bien
lieu et BHL est admis cette anecdote
révèle qu'il a besoin de la légitimité
intellectuelle que confère la
prestigieuse école de la rudulm qui a
formé certains des intellectuels
français les plus célèbres comme
Jean-Paul Sartre Raymond Haron ou Michel
fou pour parler comme Bourdieu normalien
lui aussi et qui détestait BHL pour
parler comme Bourdieu BHL a via sa
famille le capital économique mais il
n'a pas le capital culturel c'est-à-dire
le savoir et les expériences culturelles
qui permettent à un individu qui les
maîtrise de manifester son appartenance
à l'élite sociale le père de BL
entrepreneur à succès est autodidacte
c'est pas la même chose que d'être fils
de prof d'université par exemple c'est
donc à normal sub que BHL constitue son
capital culturel il se rapproche des
deux poids lourds intellectuels de
l'époque qui officier à l'école d'abord
Jacques derida le penseur emblématique
de la déconstruction et puis encore plus
de Louis altuser qui est à l'époque la
star intellectuel du marxisme grâce à
ses livres pour Marx et lire le capital
comme tous les normaliens béachel est
fasciné par le rat intellectuel
d'altucer et donc comme beaucoup de ses
camarades il adhère aux idées de Marx à
la manière
d'altuser nous sommes en 1971 1972 c'est
la fin de la scolarité de BHL à l'École
normale supérieure le secrétariat de
François mitteran appelle l'école il
cherche à joindre le responsable de la
section socialiste de l'école un certain
Bernard levvi il ne s'agit pas de BHL
mais de son homonyme l'école informe BHL
qu'il a rendez-vous avec François
miteran le lendemain à 17h que fait BHL
il sait bien que ce n'est pas lui que
mitteran veut voir mais il prend quand
même la place du Bernard Levy qui
travaille depuis des années dans l'ombre
pour une telle occasion et il ajoutera
Henry à son prénom afin que la confusion
ne soit plus possible c'est une histoire
vraie la rencontre se passe mieux que
bien miteran séduit par l'assurance du
jeune BHL décide de l'intégrer au groupe
d'experts qu'il constitue en vue de la
prochaine présidentielle une thématique
précise revient à chaque expert je dis
expert entre guillemets parce que BHL ne
connaît rien à sa thématique à lui
l'autogestion c'est-à-dire le fait que
les travailleurs dirigent eux-mêmes leur
entreprise sans patron que fait-il
est-ce qu'il demande une autre
thématique est-ce qu'il abandonne non il
propose un livre sur le sujet à Grasset
l'un des principaux éditeurs français il
se dit que quitte à devenir rapidement
un expert sur le sujet autant qu'il en
tire un bouquin Grassé refuse le projet
mais embauche BHL il devient donc
éditeur à même pas 25 ans pourquoi ce
recrutement parce que BHL correspond
parfaitement à l'évolution du business
modèle des maisons d'édition à la fin
des 30ente glorieuses pour le dire très
simplement elles veulent faire des coups
c'est-à-dire s'assurer de gros volumes
de vente en excitant l'opinion publique
bien sûr la clé d'un tel modèle ce sont
le marketing et les médias BHL un beau
et brillant jeune normalien qui sait se
vendre comme personne et qui a déjà un
réseau dans l'élite culturelle un tel
profil est parfait et quel intérêt pour
BHL de devenir éditeur ur pour le
pouvoir culturel c'est l'éditeur qui
décide de porter à la publicité
certaines idées mais aussi pour le
pouvoir social être publié chez grass
c'est très prestigieux donc BHL acqui le
pouvoir de donner du prestige social à
quelqu'un ou de s'opposer à ce qu'il en
acquire bien sûr BHL ne décide pas seul
et il est jeune mais son aide et son
influence peuvent être précieuses ça
permet d'être craint par tous ceux qui
ambitionnent d'être publié auteur
journaliste homme politique et cetera
enfin c'est aussi le moyen le plus
facile d'être soi-même publié à ma
connaissance la grande majorité sinon
l'intégralité des livres de BHL sont
sortis chez
Grasset en 1977 BL a seulement 29 ans il
est invité à apostrophe l'émission
littéraire culte de France 2 pour
l'apparution de son premier essai la
barbarie à visage humain son allure
marque les téléspectateurs à l'aise dans
une chemise blanche déboutonnée à
mi-poitrine il tient une cigarette qui
reste le plus souvent en l'air comme sur
les portraits de malero son modèle son
visage est encadré par une abondante
chevelure de de Playboy romantique le
lendemain de l'émission La Fille du
présentateur Bernard Pivot lui dit hier
j'ai vu Raino à la télé cette émission
de 1977 marque l'éclosion médiatique du
mouvement philosophique dont béachel est
le représentant le plus charismatique
les nouveaux philosophes dans cette
émission il est accompagné par l'autre
figure emblématique du mouvement André
gluxman le père du journaliste et homme
politique Raphaël gluxman cbhl qui a
baptisé le mouvement un an plus tôt en
tant qu'éditeur chez Grasset il a publié
un groupe d'auteurs qui l'englobe dans
une même revend expcation théorique le
naufrage de l'humanisme en philosophie
c'est-à-dire la fin de la foi en la
capacité de la raison à améliorer la
condition humaine le naufrage de
l'humanisme en philosophie cela ne
signifie pas le naufrage de la
philosophie il faut donc être un nouveau
type de philosophe mais la cohérence
idéologique du mouvement paraît tout de
même fragile les nouveaux philosophes se
rassemblent grosso modo autour de deux
idées le rejet du marxisme et la
condamnation des utopies les critiques
estiment qu'ils se définissent davantage
par leurs méthodes ils sont de jeunes
intellectuels médiatiques par
particulièrement habile à se mettre en
scène leur émergence est notamment liée
à la démocratisation de la télévision
dans la société française depuis les
années 1960 ils font le choix de la
légitimité médiatique contre la
crédibilité scientifique cela fonctionne
et pas seulement en France consécration
immédiate ils font la Une de
l'hebdomadaire américain Time Marx is
dead France's new philosophers speak out
les plus grands médias occidentaux leur
consacre des dossiers ou des
documentaires ils sont même invités à
donner une série de conférences au
Mexique
au milieu de l'année 2010 beaucoup de
journaux et pas seulement en France
évoquent la même nouvelle BHL et Ariel
dombal se seraient séparés et on nous
présente la nouvelle élue l'héritière
des bières Guinness pourquoi cette
séparation intéresse-elle temps les
médias parce que BHL et Ariel dombal
étaient the most famous couple in France
comme l'écrivait le magazine américain
Vanity Fair en 2003 ce qui est
intéressant dans cette anecdote ce n'est
pas la vie privée de BHL c'est que son
couple confirme sa stratégie d'influence
pour occuper l'espace médiatique il se
met en scène jusque dans sa vie
romantique la plupart des gens qui le
connaissent sont incapables de citer un
de ses livres ou un de ses concepts mais
ils suivent son couple avec Ariel dombal
d'ailleurs elle bénéficie elle aussi de
la médiatisation de leur couple en fait
ils sont pareils la notoriété d'Ariel
dombal est disproportionnée par rapport
à sa carrière d'actrice et de chanteuse
tout comme la notoriété de BHL est
disproportionnée par rapport à ses
contributions philosophiques pour le
dire très simplement les médias ne les
valorisent pas pour leur travail BHL est
omniprésent dans les médias pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'il fait très
bien ce dont les médias ont besoin leur
RA d'être capter l'attention Ariel
dombal une belle blonde excentrique est
parfaite à cet égard pardon pour
l'interruption mais j'ai une question à
vous poser vous croyez vraiment que les
gens ont lu tous les livres dont ils
parlent bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand-chose et
oui il y a 24 he dans une journée et il
faut travailler manger dormir et sortir
le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas
pas un seul secret il y en a cinq les
étudiants et les personnes les plus
cultivées les profs et les intellectuels
connaissent ces cinq secrets vous savez
vous avez lu Renant comme moi mais il se
garde bien d'en parler les gens qui les
découvrent réussissent à développer
rapidement et facilement leur culture
générale parce que leur rapport au
savoir a changé et une fois qu'ils
appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul N nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo vous vous souvenez peut-être du
fameux débat entre Nicolas Sarkozi alors
ministre de l'Intérieur et
l'intellectuel musulman tariik Ramadan
c'était en 2003 c'est pas simple pour le
ministre de l'intérieur parce que son
adversaire est un débatteur hors paèire
mais Nicolas Sarkozi s'en sort bien
comment s'est-il préparé je l'ai fourni
en munition dit BHL ce serait donc son
coaching intellectuel qui aurait fait la
différence la prestation du ministre de
l'Intérieur renforce son image de garant
de l'autorité de l'État face à
l'intégrisme islamique c'est parfait en
vue de la campagne présidentielle de
2007 BHL sera effectivement conseillé
lors de cette campagne mais de cgolen
royale et il ne se contente pas de la
soutenir publiquement dans les médias la
candidate socialiste sollicite
régulièrement son avis il s'appelle même
plusieurs fois par jour à certaine
période pourtant la relation de BHL avec
Nicolas Sarkozi ne se résume pas au
coaching pour le débat contre tariik
Ramadan en réalité ils sont amis depuis
plus de 20 ans ils sont même partis en
vacances ensemble avec leurs familles
respectiv cette anecdote montre que que
BHL n'est pas sectaire il dit que sa
famille politique c'est la gauche et
effectivement il a un gros réseau parmi
la gauche mitérandienne mais il a de
bons amis à droite par exemple Édouard
Baladur Dominique de Villepin ou encore
Bruno Le Maire et il ne s'implique pas
uniquement à gauche en 2011 il joue par
exemple un rôle clé pour convaincre le
gouvernement français d'intervenir
militairement contre Kaddafi en Libye
ces détracteurs l'accusent de vouloir
influencer le pouvoir peu importe la
famille politique lui explique qu'il
s'implique pour une cause pas pour un
camp en 2004 BHL accepte une proposition
du magazine américain via Atlantic
monthly écrire 170 ans plus tard une
version moderne de de la démocratie en
Amérique de tokville le grand classique
de la philosophie politique sur la
démocratie américaine pour cela BL doit
faire un long voyage en Amérique sur les
traces de son compatriote le but des
chroniques que publiera via Atlantic
monfly est de donner à l'Amérique un
nouveau diagnostic extérieur sur l'état
de sa démocratie American Vertigo le
livre qui compile les chroniques est un
best seller aux États-Unis cette
anecdote révèle que la notoriété de BL
n'est pas franco-française il y a deux
raisons pour lesquelles via Atlantic
monfley pense à lui pour le projet tout
d'abord il incarne l'intellectuel
parisien tel qu'on l'imagine brillant
prétentieux métaphysicien charmeur et
chic mais en même temps son personnage
est suffisamment mondialisé pour ne pas
déstabiliser le public américain la
seconde raison pour laquelle VI Atlantic
monfley pense à lui c'est qu'il est
anti-anti-américain en effet bashel
dénonce la partie de la gauche française
qui critique les États-Unis par principe
qui diabolise l'Amérique il fera donc
probablement un portrait sympathique de
l'Oncle Sam le projet est un succès
commercial et médiatique American
Vertigo apparaît dans les listes de
bestsellers du New York Times et du Los
Angeles Times la tournée de promotion de
BHL à travers les États-Unis est
triomphale il passe tellement à la
télévision que les Américains le
reconnaissent dans la rue ce succès
américain renforce son prestige en
France mais sur le plan purement
intellectuel il ne reste pas grand-chose
contrairement au VoyaG de tokville le
propos du livre est superficiel estime
les critiques et puis par rapport à son
illustre prédécesseur BHL s'est contenté
de rencontrer des stars comme Sharon
Stone déconnectés de la réalité de
l'américain
ordinaire en 2010 béashel sort un
nouveau livre de philo de la guerre en
philosophie et on peut lire à la page
122 ou bien encore Kant le prétendu sage
de kenigberg le philosophe sans vie et
sans corps par excellence dont
Jean-Baptiste botule a montré au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
dans sa série de conférences aux
néocancien du Paraguay que leur héros
était un faux abstrait et un pur esprit
de pure apparence si vous avez vu ma
vidéo sur Kant vous voyez déjà un
premier problème Kant n'est pas du tout
le philosophe sans vie et sans corps par
excellence c'est même plutôt le
contraire donc BL ne connaît pas la vie
de Kant et ensuite si on est un peu
curieux on peut se demander c'est qui ce
Jean-Baptiste botule qui a donné une
série de conférence au Paraguay un
personnage de fiction un philosophe
fictif créé pour un canular par un
journaliste du Canard Enchaîné Frédéric
pages l'article qui révèle l'erreur de
BHL devient virale non seulement en
France mais aussi aux États-Unis Unis
l'affaire botule comme on l'appelle
révèle le manque de sérieux de BHL ses
adversaires se servent de l'affaire pour
le faire passer pour un imposteur mais
dire qu'il est un imposteur en
philosophie c'est excessif il est quand
même diplômé de l'École normale
supérieure et agrégé de philosophie il a
même fini 8e au concours de l'agrégation
donc il a une formation très solide en
philosophie par ailleurs personne ne l'a
jamais traité d'imbécile au contraire
tous les témoignages y compris ceux de
ces détracteur conduisent à penser qu'il
est très intelligent donc le problème
est ailleurs le problème c'est que créer
une œuvre de ce nom ça demande de se
consacrer rentièrement à un travail
patient et minutieux BL lui est un
touche à tout pressé quant que bashel
prétend discréditer en se servant d'un
philosophe fictif Kant a attendu la fin
de la cinquantaine pour être reconnu
comme un penseur qui
compte après les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 tous les regards se
portent sur l'Afghanistan le commandant
Massou un opposant des talibans
assassiné 2 jours avant l'attentat
devient un symbole de la résistance au
fondamentalisme islamiste dans dans un
rapport remis aux autorités françaises
en 2002 BHL écrit je me souviens du
commandant Massou lors de notre première
rencontre il y a 20 ans c'était lors de
la guerre d'occupation soviétique BHL
s'était rendu sur place afin de livrer
des postes de radio à la résistance
afghane enfin ça c'est sa version
d'après une proche du commandant Massou
une médecin française qui forme des
agents de santé pour la résistance
afghane la rencontre n'aurait pas eu
lieu BHL n'aurait même pas franchi la
frontière de l'Afghanistan je ne connais
pas la vérité mais ce que montre cette
anecdote c'est que BHL se met également
en scène dans ses engagements à
l'international en fait il se donne le
rôle de l'intellectuel engagé mais il le
fait avec un modèle bien précis André
malero André malerot c'est l'aventurier
romancier devenu ministre de la Culture
du général de Gaulle contrairement à
Sartre par exemple Merot ne s'était pas
contenté de prendre la parole pour
s'engager lui se rendait sur place il a
notamment combattu avec les républicains
contre les forces de Franco à la fin des
années 30 en Espagne puis il a eu un
rôle actif dans la Résistance française
d'où sa proximité avec le général de de
Gaul BHL imite malero jusque dans la
posture comme lui il brandit sa
cigarette sans la fumer il tente de
faire trembler sa voix dans ses
interventions publicque comme Maler lors
de son célèbre hommage à Jean Moulin
certes béel se rend bien sur place au
Pakistan en Afghanistan en Bosnie au
Bangladesh en Libye en Ukraine et cetera
mais d'après les journalistes qui le
côtoient sur les théâtres d'opération ce
que cherche béachel c'est toujours à se
mettre en scène il veut des preuves
audiovisuelles de sa présence et de son
action quit à enjoliver les faits quit à
les inventer prétendent certains mais
malro ne faisait-il pas peut-être que
BHL comme son modèle malro écrit le
roman de sa
vie milieu 2010 Le Nouvel Observateur
publie un article intitulé et on frait
destrona BHL cela signifie que Bernard
Henry Levy n'est plus l'intellectuel le
plus médiatique de France tout d'abord
ces livres ne se vendent plus BHL a
pourtant donné beaucoup de bestsellers
pendant 30 ans plusieurs de ces titres
ont atteint voir dépassé les 100000
exemplaires au total grosso modo
jusqu'aux années 2000 BHL a vendu plus
d'un million de livres ce qui est énorme
mais à partir de 2010 c'est la chute il
ne dépasse plus les quelques milliers de
ventes par exemple de la guerre en
philosophie le livre de l'affaire botule
ne se vend qu'à à peine plus de 4000
exemplaires les libraires constatent que
la production de BHL se vend
exclusivement dans les quelques semaines
qui suivent lapparution les gens qui
lisent de la philosophie n'achètent plus
les livres de BHL Michel hfrey lui
enchaîne les bestsellers et à des
niveaux supérieurs au bestseller de BHL
le traité d' théologie donfy bien qu'il
n''est pas le titre le plus qui soit a
par exemple dépassé les 300000 ventes et
Michel hfry inspire davantage confiance
c'est un gros travailleur il ne commet
pas de grosses erreurs il vient d'un
milieu modeste et il ne paraît pas
déconnecté de la réalité des Français en
comparaison BHL apparaît comme le
défenseur d'une oligarchie
fané si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en science
politique en psychologie en science en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne saurez plus jamais à
cours de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toutes circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme est d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous propos
ose et le format vidéo est très adapté
pour moi qui est une mémoire
essentiellement auditive le choix des
thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent et
je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose
d'approfondissement parfaite à la fois
précis mais sans fioriture vincent lui
fait carrément ma pub j'ai d'ailleurs
recommandé votre formation à ma sœur qui
travaille comme diplomate la semaine
dernière elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre à profit dans ses discussions les
connaissances que vous avez diffusé vous
verrez d'autres témoignages comme ceci
dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme et si vous vous inscrivez
vous bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat
une fois que vous aurez TER terminer le
programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti de ce
programme et je seraai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1dé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la pensée
[Musique]
oh